la France fait face à une véritable
explosion des demandes d'asile entre
janvier et septembre 2023 environ 93000
personnes ont déposé une demande de
protection internationale à la France
leur nombre a augmenté de 12 à 14 % en 8
mois par rapport à la même période en
2022 qui était déjà une année record
l'OFPRA elle l'administration chargée de
traiter les demandes d'asile est saturée
elle a rendu plus de 90000 décisions en
8 mois et en moyenne le délai pour
traiter une demande d'asile est de 124
jours soit un peu plus de 4 mois mais le
retard va s'accentuer car les demandes
augmentent notamment depuis les arrivées
mass des 12000 migrants sur l'île
italienne de Lampedusa et la dernière
décision de la Cour de justice
européenne ne risque pas d'alléger la
situation elle impose que même en
période de tension migratoire un
ressortissant en situation irrégulière
doit pouvoir bénéficier d'un certain
délai pour quitter volontairement le
territoire l'Afghanistan reste encore le
premier pays de provenance il représente
plus de 15 % du total des demandes
enregistrées depuis le début de l'année
suivent les Guinéens les banglades les
Ivoiriens les turqus et les
ressortissants de la République
démocratique du Congo et c'est sans
oublier le poids de l'outrem la porte
d'entrée ma majeur se trouve en Guyane
où plus de 4000 demandes d'asile ont été
formulées en 8 mois 22 % sont des
Haïtiens 21 % des Afghans suivis des
Syriens et des marocain une situation
que subissent aussi nos voisins comme de
l'autre côté de la Manche au Royaume-Uni
où le niveau et le rythme actuel de
l'immigration constituent une menace
existentielle selon suela Braverman la
ministre de l'Intérieur britannique la
Convention de Genève n'est selon elle
plus adaptée à notre époque moderne en
France le projet de loi immigration
pourtant très attendu ne cesse d'être
retardé il devrait être débattu à
l'Assemblée nationale en janvier 2024
[Musique]